[Music]
have you seen this sad blank square
character called tofu on a napkin
display an emoji new emojis are
constantly being added to the Unicode
standards but since they are bundled as
a font your phone's emojis are set in
stone with each OS release well they
work with the emoji compat library part
of jetpack your app can get backwards
compatible emoji support on devices with
API level 19 and higher and get rid of
tofu for a given charge sequence emoji
compat can identify the emojis replace
them with emoji spans and then render
the glyphs on versions prior to API
level 19 well you'll still get the tofu
characters emoji compact builds on the
downloadable phone mechanism to make
sure that you always have the latest
emoji available so if you want the emoji
phone to be downloaded when your app is
installed from Play Store add this
metadata in your manifest like this the
phone will be downloaded and ready to be
used when your app starts for the first
time before being used the emoticon pad
library needs a one time asynchronous
setup we recommend doing this in your
launch activity or in the first activity
that uses emojis like this when using
the downloadable font configuration
create your phone request and create a
font request emoji compact config object
if you can't use the inaudible fonts
then you can bundle the emoji font like
this note that the size of the font is
multiple megabytes increasing your apk
size considerably on top of this you
will have to ship updates of your app
whenever the emoji font is updated
independent of the way you're using it
the initialization takes at least 150
milliseconds even up to a few seconds so
you might want to get notified about it
State for this use the register init
callback method here's a pro tip for
debugging you can enable a span
indicator like this this way emojis by
using witches that extend from app
compat widgets you can pre-process a
char sequence using the process method
you can then reuse the result instead of
the initial raw string in any widget
that can render spent
instances and needs to display the same
strap so for example if you're doing
your own custom drawing you can use this
to display emoji text if you want to add
emoji supports to a text you subclass
beyond the provided ones so for example
to an app compat checkbox you can use
the emoji textview helper class so now
with the new emoji combat library I can
see that my friend isn't asking me if I
want offal for brunch but avocados and
the answer for this is of course yes
[Applause]